hoy vamos a hablar sobre mutágenos y
carcinógenos y cómo pueden afectar al
adn pero primero quiero revisar el dogma
central de la biología molecular y cómo
la información genética de una célula se
almacena en forma de adn luego se
transcribe para formar a rm y luego se
traduce para generar una proteína los
nucleótidos del adn se transcriben en
sus formas complementarias en el rn que
luego se leen como botones o grupos de
tres para codificar aminoácidos
específicos en una proteína más grande
ahora si alteramos uno de los
nucleótidos en el adn como cambiar esta
base de timina en una base de adenina
eso afectará a la secuencia de rn y en
última instancia la proteína que genera
entonces decimos que las mutaciones son
cambios en el adn de una célula que
finalmente conducen a una producción
anormal de proteínas entonces que es un
montaje no bueno un montaje no es
cualquier sustancia química o factor
físico que puede causar mutaciones
genéticas las sustancias químicas como
ciertos venenos podrían ser mutágenos y
factores
como la luz o diferentes tipos de
radiación también podrían ser mutágenos
y clasificamos los mutágenos en dos
categorías diferentes entonces digamos
que tenemos una persona por aquí un
montaje no podría clasificarse como
endógeno si proviene del interior del
cuerpo de esta persona es decir es un
montaje no que ya se encuentra en el
organismo pero un montaje no exógeno es
aquel que proviene del exterior del
organismo afectado algo que proviene del
ambiente externo entonces cuáles son
algunos ejemplos de mutágenos endógenos
bueno los mutágenos endógenos más
significativos son los que llamamos
especies reactivas de oxígeno o ere o
las rr o son metabolitos que ocurren
naturalmente en el cuerpo humano y son
producidas por las mitocondrias durante
la fosforilación oxidativa entonces si
tenemos este tipo de aquí que está a
punto de comer una gran comida podemos
esperar que durante el metabolismo de la
comida sus mitocondrias produzcan un
montón de rr o como dos punto menos o
ion superóxido que es una molécula de
oxígeno con un electrón adicción
así como un poco de peróxido de
hidrógeno que es otra
que el cuerpo puede producir ahora las
especies reactivas de oxígeno como su
nombre lo indica contienen oxígeno como
en los ejemplos anteriores pero también
son altamente reactivas con diferentes
componentes celulares incluido el adn y
al reaccionar con el adn pueden en
realidad causar un daño significativo al
código genético de una célula un ejemplo
de este tipo de daño es la ruptura de
doble cadena y las rr o realmente pueden
romper la doble hélice de un adn en dos
partes más pequeñas y podemos ver por
qué este tipo de reacción podría causar
una mutación ya que cambia
significativamente la estructura del adn
de la célula el siguiente tipo de daño
en el adn que las rr o pueden causar es
la modificación de la base y es cuando
las bases de ácido nucleico se cambian o
intercambian y eso puede causar
mutaciones puntuales o incluso de otros
tipos ahora se estarán preguntando por
qué una célula alguna vez haría algo que
pudiera dañarla a sí misma bueno resulta
que las
y realmente tienen un par de efectos
beneficiosos en una célula y las células
tienen algunas formas de asegurarse de
que no causen daño pero a veces los
niveles de hereu aumentan mucho y las
células no pueden lidiar más con ellas
llamamos a esto estrés oxidativo y los
antioxidantes son algo que el médico
podría decir que son buenos para
nosotros y resulta que parte de lo que
hacen los antioxidantes es ayudar a
asegurarse de que las rr no dañen al adn
ahora veamos un par de ejemplos de
mutágenos exógenos y hay muchos tipos
diferentes de mutágenos exógenos pero en
realidad sólo vamos a hablar de dos los
intercala dores son un ejemplo y uno de
ellos se llama bromuro de estudio con el
que pueden estar familiarizados si
alguna vez han realizado un experimento
de pcr y lo que hará el bromuro de tibio
es saltar a una doble hélice de adn y
pegarse entre las dos cadenas y cuando
estos intercalados se intercalan en el
adn pueden deformar la estructura del
adn y causar algunos problemas graves
los análogos de bases como el zinc o
bromuro si lo que también llamamos 5b
pretenden ser una cierta base pero luego
actúan de manera diferente a lo que
normalmente haría esa base en el caso de
5 veo es un análogo de brasil o y se
parece mucho a él pero una vez que se
incorpora al adn puede cambiar entre dos
formas diferentes en su forma seto se
combinará mejor con adenina y si está en
forma de enol se combinará mejor con
guanina ahora si están familiarizados
con la química orgánica pueden saber que
5b puede cambiar entre sus formas seto
lleno mediante algo llamado reacción de
automatización y en general podemos ver
como este análogo de base podría inducir
mutaciones en una cadena de adn lo
último de lo que vamos a hablar es sobre
que es un carcinógeno los carcinógenos
pueden ser mutágenos no todos lo son
pero en general se puede decir que un
carcinógeno es algo que puede provocar
cáncer lo que recordemos es cuando las
células de un organismo se dividen sin
control y pueden formar grandes masas de
células llamadas tumores algunos
carcinógenos funcionarán así
mutaciones en el adn que conducen al
cáncer pero a veces podrían llevar a
cabo sus efectos simplemente aumentando
la velocidad a la que se divide en un
montón de células sin afectar realmente
su adn algunos ejemplos de carcinógenos
son el tabaco que proviene de
cigarrillos el asbesto que solía usarse
como aislamiento para el hogar e incluso
la radiación ultravioleta entonces que
aprendimos bueno primero aprendimos que
los montaje no son sustancias químicas o
factores físicos que pueden aumentar la
probabilidad de que ocurran mutaciones
genéticas y luego aprendimos que los
carcinógenos
son cosas que conducen al cáncer y
aunque también pueden ser mutágenos no
lo son necesariamente